what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so getting into DC rebirth one of
the funny things is I've been seeing
comments recently of people asking me to
do more DC videos we literally alternate
every other day
it's like Marvel DC Marvel DC like
Monday Wednesday and Friday are the
Marvel Days Sunday Tuesday and Thursday
or the DC days and then Saturday is when
we do like Omega Beyond omega-level
mutant so I don't really know what those
guys are talking about but with regards
to Hal Jordan and the Green Lantern
Corps remember this story deals more
with like the Green Lantern Corps in
space and it's kind of interesting I
didn't even think about it until earlier
today but in DC Comics you've always had
like the Green Lantern Corps and in the
Green Lantern books or at least you did
for a while the Green Lantern Corps
dealt with the Green Lantern characters
outside of like Earth's Green Lantern's
basically and then you had the Green
Lantern stories which dealt with Earth's
Green Lantern's so who was always kind
of interesting he was like the Superman
Action Comics you know line of stories
but the idea here is that this basically
gives us one set of events that
essentially leads into another and what
this does is it basically creates what I
like to call the Sinestro Corps Civil
War because that's basically what it is
now initially but this seems pretty
straightforward right in the stem so
there's basically some guy who works on
a giant Bank it's like one of these big
cosmic banks that exists the biggest one
in the universe
is where a lot of like Universal
companies and things like that store
their money the banks effectively robbed
really well at least a campaign is being
launched to rob this Bank and the reason
for that is because there's basically
just a guy who works there Penny's like
whatever let's rob this place I mean
there's no reason why we can't this of
course leads into the Green Lantern
Corps now of course the Green Lantern
Corps at this moment in time serves as a
police force of source but remember the
Green Lantern's and the Sinestro Corps
are basically merged into a singular
group which is kind of interesting
because when the Sinestro Corps first
popped up they were the mortal enemies
of the Green Lantern's the idea though
was that the Sinestro Corps was led by
Thal Sinestro and the result is that
once he was believed to have been killed
in the first story arc of DC rebirth the
leadership of the Sinestro Corps fell to
his daughter a former Green Lantern who
joined the yellow lanterns now of course
we're going back on Sundays and going
through and explaining all that Green
Lantern mythos and so if you're curious
as to why that happens all that comes
out on Sundays were actually at blackest
night at the moment worse like the rise
of the Black Lantern cores and all the
dead superheroes are coming back to life
but the arrival
the sinestro and Green Lantern cores
again they're really just more of a
peacekeeping force they basically grab
these guys they whisk him away they're
taken back to mojo the planet of the
Green Lantern Corps and they're
basically made to stand trial and that's
really about it
the issue with this is that we end up
finding out a member of the Green
Lantern Corps is basically getting sick
now this Green Lantern is a guy by the
name of tomar - and he's actually the
son of tomar right the reason why I
bring this up and the reason why I'm
kind of taking a second to talk about
this is because tomar to and tomar a
have a pretty long-standing history in
the Green Lantern landscape really more
tomar ray than a Sun - Omar - but the
idea is that tomar ray was one of the
original Green Lantern's that is to say
one of the individuals who fought
alongside Hal Jordan before he went
crazy was possessed by parallax and
killed all the Green Lantern's the
result is that when Omar - was given the
ring of his father there was some
animosity when Hal Jordan returned
during the events of the original Green
Lantern rebirth but as time progressed
tomar too began to develop a kind of
respect for Hal Jordan and then
eventually became a mutual thing where
tomar - came to the realization that Hal
Jordan had basically turned over a new
leaf he's proved himself time and time
again in the Green Lantern stories to be
one of the most important and best
aspects of their team really this guy
who in a lot of ways embodies what it
means to be a Green Lantern the reason
why this is important actually becomes
clear because it's the focal point of
this story and the reason why everything
ends up happening and so what we do is
we pick up with the aftermath of the
last story that I believe we covered the
one called prism of time it was
basically the idea that Kyle Rayner son
had come from the future and then
basically was able to possess pure
willpower the result is that he used his
abilities to effectively destroy all the
members of the Green Lantern's Alou
seemed to be enemies of them the result
is that it ended up with Kyle Rayner
facing off against his son and
ultimately his son was killed this is
important because Kyle Rayner hid this
fact from Sir onic not - of course sir
onic being the daughter of a thousand
Estero now of course sir onic is
basically trying to escape her father's
legacy
right like FAL Sinestro was a Green
Lantern who abuses power he fell to the
dark side so to speak form the Sinestro
Corps and it was an enemy of the Green
Lantern's ever since she's been trying
to escape that now over the course of
geoff johns run and again we'll get
through this kind of stuff she basically
found herself in a relationship with
kyle rayner the issue with this is that
when the son of kyle rayner a
in the present day how Rana realized it
was his son but he didn't realize it
until after his son was dead and so
because of this when he realized that it
was basically the child of himself and
sir on ik he actually hid that
information from her the other half of
this is he's basically trying to
convince her to join the Green Lantern's
under the idea that he looks to the
future and says okay
our son basically became a villain and
maybe it's because of the fact that
cirrhotic fell back to the Sinestro
Corps
maybe it's because of any number of
things you know any any situation that
can lead to their child becoming a bad
guy and so what he ended up looking to
do was basically move her towards the
aspect of being a Green Lantern without
her really knowing what his true
motivations were so again there's a
couple plots going on with that kind of
a thing now in terms of the Green
Lantern's realize in the fact that one
of their members had killed a member of
the Sinestro Corps this comes by way of
one of the Raiders but where the Green
Lantern's saying we're gonna lock you up
we're gonna throw you in jail you're
gonna stand trial for your crimes his
answer is no you're not you're gonna let
me go because I have video evidence to
prove that one of your Green Lantern's
killed a yellow lantern now in normal
circumstances it wouldn't matter but
remember with ceramic leading the
Sinestro Corps and Jon Stewart of Earth
leading the Green Lantern Corps they
have a truce and so because of this when
they're faced with this information
there's a little bit of a rift in the
Green Lanterns all the way up at the
very top which is to say how Jordan
largely considered to be the greatest of
the Green Lantern's the most decorated
and Jon Stewart who's currently running
the show the reason behind this is
because for Hal Jordan the question has
to be asked what's going on here is any
of this true but at the same time he
doesn't want to believe it Jon Stewart
is a pragmatic man if he's given a piece
of evidence that may have some validity
then his goal is to seek it out and see
whether or not it's absolutely true so
really he's a lot more logical here
whereas Hal Jordan is thinking more
emotionally than anything else now the
other half of this is that for Jon
Stewart if this is true if it's true
that a member of the Green Lantern Corps
killed a member of the Sinestro Corps
and that is strictly forbidden according
to the truce they have it will bring
everything crashing down because one of
these Green Lantern's went rogue which
is also an indication that he does not
have as much control of the Green
Lantern's as he thought he did and so
again this all gets kind of wild but
ultimately we end up picking up with
cirrhotic traveling to the morgue to see
the son of car later of course again she
doesn't really know the fact that it
as her son but going through here and
performing all these different studies
because of the fact that she's a doctor
DNA analysis different things like that
she's basically told this being has two
sides to its DNA one side is human the
father being kyle rayner the other side
is peruvian i guess is how you pronounce
it ah the child s erotic not to now of
course this sends her immediately over
the edge because what she's basically
being told here if she has fought
alongside in a conflict that resulted in
her own son being killed this is massive
not only that when Hal Jordan travels to
see Tamar - he basically ends up
discovering at the same time that Jon
Stewart does that - marks who was the
one who killed this member of the
Sinestro Corps now of course Jon Stewart
finds out by virtue of the fact that Guy
Gardner another one of the Green
Lantern's and our kill Oh a member of
the Sinestro Corps both of whom were
working together had basically gone on
this mission to essentially grab this
spot that was basically observing the
entire thing and they had looked at the
video footage and came to the
realization that Omar too had come into
this con before Hal Jordan he's coming
across circumstantial evidence and
that's why these things are totally
different Jon Stewart's got video proof
Hal Jordan just comes across
tomar - who's using his willpower to
keep this Sinestro ring confined now
this is also kind of an interesting
situation because it's not something DC
really talks about so much which is to
say what happens when a green lantern
goes to sleep but before we get to that
what we end up doing is we pick up with
with tomar - again encountering this
member of the Sinestro Corps and this
guy basically says look I will never
honor a truce between the Green
Lantern's and the Sinestro Corps that's
never going to happen and this guy was
basically a serial killer of children no
less and so there's really no mercy on
really any round with regards to this
guy but the issue is that green lanterns
are designed as a peacekeeping and a
police force they're not designed to be
this strong on of some dictator
somewhere so they can't just take the
law into their own hands they're not
judge jury and executioner and so
because of this when tomar - is
basically goaded and this guy
essentially says hey look yeah I'll go
to jail and I'll stand trial and I'll go
through their little science cells
essentially the the prison of the Green
Lanterns and I'll break out just like I
did before and I'll go back and I'll
kill kids again ultimately tomar - kills
them now in truth this makes sense it
makes it makes perfect sense the purpose
of prison is the hope that they can
basically find Redemption but some
individuals are not look
for redemption they don't believe that
what they do is wrong or if they do know
it's wrong they don't care they enjoy
doing it this member of the Sinestro
Corps was one of those and so in a
moment of anger and in a moment of Wrath
tomar too kills him in cases as ring and
that basically tells us partner you saw
nothing and you heard nothing we end up
finding out when tomar to's talking to
Hal Jordan the reason why he's been
getting sick is because of the fact that
in order to keep this yellow lantern
ring encased in this box of willpower he
can never sleep this is kind of cool
because again this is basically the idea
that when a Green Lantern goes to sleep
they presumably take off the Rings any
number of things and the result is that
they are effectively powerless in this
instance this guy has been using his
willpower day and night 24 hours a day
non-stop never sleeping and has pushed
his bi to the point of physical
exhaustion the problem with this is that
again in the face of this circumstantial
evidence how Jordan doesn't want to
believe it's true and that makes sense
because he's basically being told one of
your oldest friends and one of the best
members of the Green Lantern Corps
killed a member of the Sinestro Corps in
cold blood dismembered the Sinestro
Corps said fine I will go to your
science cells that is a damning piece of
evidence because it's basically this guy
saying I give up
it's really the idea really the goal of
Jon Stewart to sweep it under the rug
and to keep it all very hush-hush
now this is huge with regards to Jon
Stewart because he's always been a man
who had this like moral viewpoint right
where he says okay there's right there's
wrong sure there's circumstantial
evidence but in the end we have to abide
by the law and the truth what he's
basically doing here is he's trying to
play both sides he's trying to
essentially say okay look this member of
the Green Lantern Corps committed a
crime against the Sinestro Corps
normally we would basically have him
executed or we would basically kick him
out but if anybody finds out that he
killed a member of the Sinestro Corps
everything we built is being destroyed
it's gonna come crashing down and so
it's his idea to basically take this guy
throw him in a science cell he'll never
be seen or heard from again
and no one will find out what it was
that he did make it go away
now of course transitioning back over to
the whole scenario with with surrounded
natsu and with kyle rayner she's
basically just pissed
she is mad as hell because in her mind
kyle rayner denied her something that
she should have had the right to know
kyle rayner basically knew that this guy
who died
their kid she was part of this whole
situation and never once was she told
this is a huge betrayal of trust on the
highest levels kyle rayner he basically
said come back to the Green Lanterns I
want you here I need you in my life all
the while hiding something of such a
high degree now if he had gone to her
almost immediately after he found out
and said okay hey look here's everything
that I know
maybe cirrhotic would be understanding
maybe she wouldn't the issue is that
Kyle did not afford her that opportunity
she had to find out the hard way she had
to be blindsided by this fact and so in
her anger and in her wrath she
completely falls back down to the role
of her father Sinestro now this is crazy
and it's actually pretty interesting
that this happens because cirrhotic
again had spent so much time trying to
assure people she was not like her
father she spent so much time trying to
fight that aspect of herself and prove
to herself above all others that she was
not fall sinestro all it took was the
betrayal from a close friend to make
that happen and that's really the center
point of all this Killing Joke example
all that ever takes is one bad day for
Thal Sinestro who was trying to impose
order on a planet fallen prey to
government corruption to corporate
corruption to people who just stuck
their head in the sand hoping the
world's problems would go away it was
him trying to restore order to all that
and being banished from the Green
Lantern Corps for abusing his power for
cirrhotic is her experiencing the trust
of someone that she loved of someone
that she trusted more than almost any
other and so it's a very very big deal
because as soon as this happens and of
course when it comes to you know Jon
Stewart making his discussion not
revealing the fact that a member of the
Green Lantern Corps killed a member of
the Sinestro Corps ultimately word gets
around and when it does all hell breaks
loose the Sinestro Corps come bolting
for this guy and they immediately like
they they're out for blood they want
this guy gone they want him dead of
course this leads directly to Hal Jordan
to Jon Stewart basically drawing lines
in the sand and saying okay here's the
where's worth things stand you know Guy
Gardner shows up with the body of
coroner says somebody and printed us and
that stroke or symbol on his chest not
knowing that it's cirrhotic and it's
then basically saying hey look everybody
needs to calm down everybody needs to
relax only for serrata to show up and
say I'm the one who branded kyle rayner
in her anger here she's speaking out of
out of fear she's beating out of the
fact that she's emotionally
that's really what this says and in her
mind experiencing such a huge betrayal
kyle rayner
extends out into everything else being
heartbroken and saying well this
alliance was never gonna work this
alliance was never gonna happen is
somebody just getting frustrated and
just tearing the house apart out of
anger he's essentially saying we were
all duped we were all tricked we were
told that things would be great we were
told that things would be amazing we
were brought here at a Mogo they allowed
us to build a central power battery the
source of our power they allowed us to
build it here so that we could all be
even but the truth is that we never work
and we know that because a member of the
Sinestro Corps kills a member of the
Green Lantern Corps well man justice
needs to be served something needs to be
done but a member of the Green Lantern
Corps kills a member of the Sinestro
Corps well I mean you know let's not be
too hasty in our rush to judgment you
know so because of that what she's
seeing is a contradiction on behalf of
the Green Lantern's now heavy is the
crown that's the price Jon Stewart is
bank because he's literally trying to
hold all this together and none of it's
working if so what he basically does is
he says look here's how things are gonna
be those of you guys who are faithful
those of you guys who want to remain on
the side of good who believe that good
can come out of this alliance stand on
this side a lot people who don't agree
go join sir on it half the Sinestro
Corps goes to her side half the Sinestro
Corps stays on the Green Lantern side
and it just Oh roughs into this massive
battle it's essentially just Green
Lantern versus Sinestro Corps member
versus Sinestro Corps member it's
literally a Sinestro Corps Civil War the
problem is that it does not last very
long and the reason why is because what
ended up happening is that in the middle
of all this Jon Stewart effectively put
this sort of caveat in the central power
battery of the Sinestro Corps in a sense
that if he basically execute this
command codename khatma what it
essentially does is it shuts down the
Sinestro Corps block or trains it
overrides them and keeps them from
attacking Green Lantern's this does not
help his case what this does if anything
is it actually instills a more
entrenched belief among the members of
the Sinestro Corps that Jon Stewart in
the Green Lantern's never trusted him
but for Jon Stewart he's also got a
legitimate argument here again when the
Sinestro Corps war first picked up first
picked off the Sinestro Corps took no
prisoners they came across the Green
Lantern that Green Lantern was dead
every single time there were no
prisoners taken no quarter given so from
Stewart's perspective it's a legitimate
gripe to take but one is up happening is
cirrhotic grabs the faithful Sinestro
Corps members
takes off into space and says look we'll
find our own way we will form a new base
of operations we will find a place that
we can call our own and we'll call it a
day that'll basically be it now the
reason why this is also a really big
moment too is because we're John Stewart
and everybody's like okay look
everything's kind of quelled we have the
faithful here on our side we don't know
when they'll come back but it'll be
somewhere else later on down the line
for right now the conflict is done
what we end up doing is picking up on
the planet chord in the antimatter
universe and what we end up finding out
is that FAL Sinestro is not dead he's
very much alive he's actually just been
resurrected and so all we have to do is
just wait until his body physically
returns back to his normal state then
when it does the question becomes what
happens to the Sinestro Corps after that
is a really exciting time if you're a
fan of these line of stories but with
that being said guys if you are new here
to come as explained make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
rod core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you